the largest monument in europe is
located in leipzig germany and was built
on the location napoleon surrendered
[Music]
completed in 1913 the monument to the
battle of the nations is named after the
battle that took place a hundred years
earlier between napoleon and his allies
and the united armed forces of russia
prussia austria and sweden the fight
involved around 600 000 troops from over
20 countries and was the largest
european battle prior to world war one
at the base of the monument is the
archangel michael
above him are giant stone guards who
circle the structure
inside the ground floor there are eight
night statues who represent the fallen
soldiers they are joined by other
smaller figures known as the guardians
of the dead
these guardians watch over all the souls
who have been lost
all of these statues on the ground floor
are shadowed by the 31-foot giants on
the second story known as the hall of
fame
each of these represent the four
historic qualities attributed to the
german people
bravery
faith
sacrifice
and fertility
during the communist era when many
monuments were torn down this one
survived because the structure
commemorates a war when the russians and
germans fought together against a common
enemy
the scale of the monument inspires awe
with a height of nearly 300 feet
towering over leipzig and reminding all
who view it of the battles of the past
you